[Music]
Jason is in Baltimore
hi Jason how are you I'm good sir how
are you better than I deserve what's up
so I'm having I shouldn't say I'm doing
well because I'm probably not my wife
and I had been together for six years
and we've been struggling with a lot of
issues well one of them is finances but
on top of it my wife's had various
issues such as drinking problems so much
as she drove our daughter home drunk
from school one day and I caught her mmm
oh my gosh you have no clue so I
actually had to call the police because
she kept lying to me and denying it and
she still mad at me to this day for it
so I've been trying to work through the
baby steps you know I discovered your
show probably four months ago and I
finished watched them and we're on step
two and as I'm paying that all she keeps
racking it up and she's in collections
now for QVC for probably like the third
or fourth time so I'm trying to work a
little bit more money or work a little
bit more overtime to pay it all you
can't I'll earn this you've got
dysfunction going on in your household
that you got to solve where you'll never
be able to prosper
well we trick thing is we've been going
to therapy on and off for probably seven
years and we go to the therapist and my
wife admits all these things she has
drinking issues she's actually is she
still drink at today what that sir is
she still drinking today
no but how long has she been dry uh
we've had two bouts of her stopped
drinking how long has she been dry it
probably two months okay all right and
we go to the therapist and she admits
all these issues that she has she has a
spending problem
Jezza self-image issue and she tells me
all these things and then when we get
home the story changes now she's in debt
I'm trying to work on the collection and
I told her to call and just say hey I
told her don't give any money you know
don't give them any accounts just find
out what kind of payment plan options we
had
so she called and she started a payment
plan option and then what I told her she
shouldn't have done that she got mad and
said well you told me to and I don't
know what there's two or three things
going on here one of these things is a
money thing the other is the different
issues that she's struggling with that
are causing the money thing money
problems are very seldom the problem
they're almost always the symptom of
something else that's going on okay
and in her case she's struggling with a
lot of different issues that are driving
her bad money decisions and you're
attached to her by a wedding ring and
that that's causing you to sync with her
and so we you know we've got to help her
finish healing with the alcohol issues
and with the impulsive spending issues
and those kinds of things and all of
that can be done you more through all
that but they're not independent of each
other and so you can't continue to lay
them on top of each other you probably
need a different therapist because I
don't hear much progress being made here
probably need a good marriage counselor
from a good church that will walk you
through this I recommend the two of you
get into the church find a good pastor
that'll walk with both of you and help
you deal with these issues and get on a
good solid ground emotionally and
spiritually then the financial stuff
will start to turn around but we'll put
you through Financial Peace University
while you're dealing with it so hold on
I'll have Laura pick up and get you
signed up for a class hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]